please do something 730 this morning
again a nosebleed loss of focus loss of
balance muscle pain bad cough
it's an invisible tsunami of methane is
blowing into these neighborhoods right
now you're totally engulfed by it and
lightheaded instantly because the
methane part replaced his oxygen smells
like strong rotten eggs mixed with
sulfur that's my best description was
selling it was bad to a point where when
you step outside you understood off
I didn't have any nine bloody nose
Tatiana has been the one that has had
multiple experiences with major rashes
all over her body some days her legs are
covered with big red rashes some days
four stomachs covered with big red
rashes oh go away few hours later and
then astronaut will come close to porter
ranch here we are again starting all
over we first smelled the gas leak on
october 23rd on october 24th we call the
gas company numerous times and they said
there's normal venting
call the gas company and said I heard
that there's a leak at your facility is
there and they said no sir there's no
leak everything's fine it's normal
maintenance I go the fire department
told me there's a leak no sir there's no
leak what a bunch of lying motherfuckers
there's no treatment except for leave
the area that's what they said if this
persists just get out of the area
Gary
out right
about life family
you